[Musica]
quando ero piccolo c'era questo cartone
animato di Felix il gatto questo
episodio di Felix il gatto che ho
riguardato talmente tante volte che l'ho
imparato a memoria ma non solo le
battute anche il ritmo di tutti i suoni
e le musiche di questo cartone animato
parararararararararara
pum pum pum Io ho un rapporto
particolare con i cartoni animati adoro
quelli che hanno un minutaggio contenuto
quindi i cartoni animati della Warner
Willy il Coyote è uno dei miei preferiti
mentre quando iniziano ad andare molto
più lunghi come un film Quindi quando
superano 40 minuti un'ora e diventano
letteralmente dei lungometraggi perduti
interesse completamente Fatevi I Fatti
Vostri Questo è un limite mio ci convivo
io quindi sì ho visto la maggior parte
dei film della Disney quando ero piccolo
ma soltanto una volta una storia
particolarmente scioccante come dice
Elisa trocante Infatti della Disney è su
Disney Plus Preferisco guardare i corti
degli anni trenta 40 e 50 ma non vi
incazzate se il mio cervello che
funziona così le sinapsi gli impulsi
elettrici danno quel quell'effetto è
inutile che vi menta dicendovi Sì il mio
film preferito Il Re Leone 3 Non è vero
piuttosto che 100 lungometraggi Disney
preferisco una puntata di Zig e Sharko
Ma tutto questo per raccontarvi la
storia di oggi una storia che come al
solito qualcuno da qualche dimensione mi
lancia addosso capita per caso e a
quanto pare questa è la mia vita ormai
da sempre mentre spulciavo la mia
piccola collezione di 8 mm che ogni
tanto ritiro fuori da un cassetto
polveroso mi ritrovo questo Le avventure
di gatto Evaristo questo ipotetico
cartone animato che sembrerebbe una
parodia di Gatto Silvestro con dietro
tre dei suoi fantastici amici ce lo da
un po' Ma è una di quelle momento in cui
non pensi dici vabbè E lì ce l'ho Non
importa prima o poi lo guarderò Ma prima
di guardarlo Fammelo cercare online
vediamo cos'è chi l'ha fatto ma se avete
aperto questo video e Conoscete il mio
canale sapete già la risposta non ho
trovato niente da nessuna cazzo di parte
nulla il vuoto cosmico non un frame
nessuno che ne parlasse da nessuna parte
di internet e voi adesso mi
accompagnerete nel viaggio che è stata
la ricerca di gatto
evaristotele change
[Musica]
la ricerca non ha portato nessun tipo di
informazione ma letteralmente nessuno
L'unica cosa che ho trovato È che alcune
persone su eBay Lo vendono gatto
Evaristo e sembra esattamente lo stesso
8 mm che ho io ma ve lo posso assicurare
non c'è un filmato non c'è una clip non
c'è neanche un singolo frame di questo
cartone animato Allora se avessi avuto
soltanto l'unica copia esistente sulla
faccia della terra di questa cosa qua
avrei detto ok o sono incappato in
qualcosa di particolare ma altre persone
lo vendono Quindi come è possibile che
non ci sia niente da nessuna parte e
anche chi lo vende spesso scrive non
visionato quindi l'unica cosa da fare è
vederlo e io il mio personale proiettore
8 mm per bambini piccoli Quindi perfetto
tutto quello che dobbiamo fare
esattamente
[Musica]
Eccolo qua vedi poi Noi spegniamo le
luci sto mettendo il
nastro nell'altra bobina per farlo
arrotolare poi
[Musica]
Cosa ti aspetti Non lo so
mi si vede un po' pochissimo e la prima
riproduzione forse addirittura di questa
pellicola di gatto evaristobre film
vieni qua Basta pronto Vai
aspetta
[Applauso]
Allora mi sa che non è adatto perché la
pellicola era parecchio
spostata ed arriva immediatamente il
primo intoppo Le avventure di gatto
Evaristo non è un 8 mm è un super 8 mm
ed infatti il proiettore non riesce a
visualizzarlo come si deve detto in
parole povere la differenza fra un 8 mm
un super 8 e che il frame che contiene
l'immagine in un super 8 è leggermente
più grande di quella di 8 mm quindi
sulla tela veniva tagliato Ma c'è
un'altra cosa che io ho Dov'è Eccola qua
questa monnezza presa da Amazon Movie
Digital che digitalizza appunto le
pellicole Vi faccio una recensione al
volo Non compratelo
link affilato in descrizione No però
sono i rischi del mestiere quando vuoi
fare una roba che non conosci
Le avventure di Gatteo ok No ma poi
sarebbe stato incredibile Se fossi
riuscito io a digitalizzare E infatti
non è venuto una belga o meglio qualcosa
è venuto fuori sono tornato dopo
mezz'ora ma il video Sta ancora andando
avanti e credo ad un terzo ad un quarto
della pellicola ma lo sta facendo e lo
farò partire domani il sotto mia
supervisione perché adesso devo andare a
casa e quindi niente
non mi posso distrarre un attimo che ho
finito ha finito di sbobinare
letteralmente tutto quanto ho passato la
pellicola adesso porterò l'sd che
dovrebbe essere qua dietro e visionerò
il risultato Incrocio le dita perché
secondo me non è venuto benissimo Però
con quello che abbiamo fatto una cosa
c'è Signore e signori per la prima volta
online In anteprima mondiale il primo
frame in cui appare gatto Evaristo
ed è Gatto Silvestro
Gatto Silvestro alla fine sono riuscito
a digitalizzarlo ma talmente male che la
mia cartella è divisa in tantissimi
piccoli file di un cartone animato di 7
minuti perché continuava a stopparsi
continuava continuavamo a fermarlo e
farlo ripartire però ce l'ha fatta ma
non lo conto per buono da qui
Tralasciando un attimo il filmato
animato sono partite due ricerche una di
polistampa SpA Milano perché sul retro
della scatola c'è scritto che questo è
una produzione polistampa SpA Milano
Perfetto Fammi cercare polistamp SpA
Milano mortacci sua Non si trova niente
L'unica polistampa che ho trovato è
quella di Firenze che fa libri c'è
un'altra polistante Spa che fa arte
funeraria e io ho il sospetto che non
sia la stessa polistante spa c'è una
polistamp spa Milano che è una
copisteria e sviluppo foto ma dice che
nel 2021 aveva Zero dipendenti e
tecnologia ha un nome diverso È sempre
una copisteria ma un nome completamente
diverso Quindi non credo fosse quello e
l'altra ricerca è data dal nome
dell'animatore che ha creato gatto
Evaristo si legge poco ma è Giancarlo
Marchesi cazzo abbiamo il nome
dell'animatore Fammi cercare il nome
dell'animatore ma non è possibile
L'unica cosa che si riesce a trovare di
Giancarlo Marchesi e che ha lavorato a
la linea un personaggio di Osvaldo
cavandoli che non sto qui ad
approfondire che Marchesi da animatore
ha solo animato durante il periodo del
Carosello tra il 69 e il 76 ma ma una
cosa che sono uscita a notare da quel
poco che si vede dalla digitalizzazione
che ho fatto io i personaggi parlano ma
un'altra cosa che il digitale serve
merda non fa estrapolare audio perché se
lo avessimo potremmo sentire le voci dei
doppiatori quindi si va alla ricerca per
le strade di Torino di uno studio che
possa digitalizzare un per 8 mm con
audio
faccio una piccola ricerca e scopro che
in pieno centro a Torino c'è uno studio
Che digitalizza super 8 e loro
gentilmente mi dicono che possono
digitalizzare la pellicola in 15 giorni
magari riesco a trovare qualcuno che lo
fa un po' più velocemente ma non serve
cercare sono proprio loro che mi
Indicano un altro studio molto ma molto
più vicino a casa mia in questo
complesso di uffici mi apre la porta
questo signore simpaticissimo di una
dolcezza infinita che
chiacchieriamo insieme un pochino del
più e del meno su sulla appunto la
digitalizzazione dei Super 8 e su tutto
quello che la le famiglie perdono perché
non fanno questo processo e mi Promette
che in pochi giorni me lo avrebbe ridato
e durante questo periodo due colpi di
scena il primo facendo l'ennesima
ricerca cambiando le parole chiave ogni
volta cercavo polistamp SpA Milano gatto
Evaristo Poli SpA Milano 8 mm gatto
Evaristo 8 mm Insomma cambiando l'ordine
degli addendi Sono riuscito anche a
cambiare il risultato di poco in un post
di un forum nel 2012 ho trovato questo
Salve sono riuscito ad acquisire quattro
cartoni animati italiani con lo stesso
titolo mi chiedevo se qualcuno potesse
darmi delle informazioni più
approfondite io ho detto guarda qui
qualcun altro ha trovato le avventure di
gatto evariste sta chiedendo nel 2012 in
un forum a caso qualche spiegazione il
titolo e
miagolavo e gedeone compagnia polistampa
Spa Oh e questo cambia molto le cose
perché vuol dire che polistamp non ha
fatto solo Evaristo ma ha fatto anche
qualcosa chiamato miagolare e gedeone
cerco miagolava e gedeone e trovo una
ceppa veramente Ho trovato solo un libro
per bambini chiamato gedeone una storia
d'amore mi sparo in bocca adesso manca
poco eh ve lo dico l'altro Twist è che
mentre aspettavo la digitalizzazione in
quei giorni lì siamo andati ad un
mercatino e lì dentro una vetrina c'era
uno stock di 10 15 8 mm e in fondo
piccolino piccolino c'è di nuovo gatto
Evaristo io non l'avevo mai più visto è
proprio in quei giorni lo ritrovo anche
se in un formato molto più piccolo in
teoria Questo vuol dire che è una
versione un po' più corta anche se hanno
la stessa copertina proprio la stessa
confezione identica l'unica differenza è
che sul fondo c'è il titolo Evaristo e
Filiberto all'ultimo scherzo Chi sarà
Filiberto dei tre il cane Il topo
l'uccellino dobbiamo aspettare la
digitalizzazione che arriva con un
messaggio con un sms old school mi piace
e Mica mi chiede la mail per inviarmi un
MP4 gli ho dato anche la custodia questo
video abbiamo il DVD di gatto Evaristo
il primo che ero l'unico devo dire
esistente degli altri paesi
masterizzato ovviamente però e adesso
sono curioso di vedere se è venuto bene
il video ma soprattutto se dall'audio
possiamo dedurre che ci sia un
doppiatore qualcuno Io lo spero
tantissimo
Non avete idea di quanto sia incredibile
Questa cosa per me sì ha l'audio e si è
doppiato Ecco fatto
ed ora a noi due solo che noto subito
che ha gravissimi problemi di
sincronizzazione tra video e audio
causato Probabilmente dal vecchio lume
della pellicola Quindi ho fatto un
piccolissimo restauro ci ho messo le
mani Anch'io ho estrapolato il file dal
DVD e lo risincronizzato io quindi com'è
è carino è carino non posso dire è un
cartone animato di 7 minuti dove c'è
questo gatto che fa i dispetti al cane
incredibilmente non è per niente Gatto
Silvestro ma molto più Willy il coyote
colui che costruisce i binari e poi da
binari spunto un treno quello è proprio
Willy Coyote e anche creativo allo
stesso modo con lui che inghiotte una
scatoletta per diventare ventriloqui ma
non la usa per parlare perché lui sa già
parlare la usa per sparare un fulmine
con la bocca e animare degli oggetti
come una cassetta degli attrezzi che
abbaia
[Musica]
e la scatola sopra è scritta in italiano
quindi questo conferma che al 100% una
produzione italiana ed è già qualcosa ma
non è l'unica cosa che ciccia fuori
questi sette minuti non fanno tutti
parte dello stesso episodio ma è diviso
in due il principale che prende tre
quarti del minutaggio dove loro sono
doppiati e dell'episodio della voce del
ventriloquo L'altro invece è soltanto
una porzione finale piccolina un po'
diversa nel senso non c'è una
transizione tra un episodio e l'altro ma
si nota che è diverso perché questo è
muto cioè c'è solo la musica loro non si
parlano non ci sono dialoghi quindi c'è
proprio un pezzo attaccato all'episodio
precedente ma non è la cosa più strana
Quella arriva a 2 minuti
[Musica]
veramente tremendo
Vediamo adesso cosa combina
[Musica]
veramente tremendo Vediamo adesso cosa
combina Io ero convinto che questo fosse
il narratore esterno sai come si faceva
una volta ma no sia perché la voce
arriva quasi da fuori campo e a un certo
punto proprio alla fine della frase si
sente un audio lontano di un televisore
acceso
ma soprattutto dopo la voce
riapparecchio
Accidenti Chi sarà parlare il
proprietario del Super 8 sarà Giancarlo
Marchesi sei tu Giancarlo magari
qualcuno di polistampa Milano negli anni
70 che ha deciso di registrare il nonno
che ha regalato al nipote Questo
supereroe e voleva fare lo splendido
parlando di Gesù Io adesso mi prendo
neanche me le strappo tipo velcro e mi
ammazzo Perché come
quindi mi sono detto facciamo la prova
del nove se nella mia versione c'è la
voce registrata fuori campo proviamo ad
andare a digitalizzare anche quest'altra
versione vedere se qui c'è la voce fuori
campo e secondo voi questa versione ce
l'ha o non ce l'ha la voce fuori campo
diventa una tradizione ogni tot viene
opportuno sempre più piccolo così
Bisogna saper vivere purtroppo non ce
l'ha sapete perché Perché è un altro
cazzo di episodio di gatto Evaristo
completamente diverso dove lui si fa gli
scherzi col topo però anche se io vedo i
dialoghi purtroppo non ha l'audio e il
Signore Credo mi abbia messo una musica
copyright free in sottofondo o degli
aggiornamenti mentre montavo o ricercato
ogni cosa di cui parlavo nel video per
essere sicuro che non ci fossero
aggiornamenti e durante la ricerca di
Giancarlo Marchesi sono andato a
ricercare gli animatori della linea e in
mezzo a tutta la lista guarda un po' c'è
un Loretta Marchesi saranno parenti
facciamo l'ultimo tentativo scriviamo
Giancarlo e Loretta Marchesi animatori e
guarda un po' lo studio glm questo
studio ha collaborato con un sacco di
case di produzione ha fatto una linea ha
fatto la Pimpa di Altan e ha collaborato
con l'autore di Disney Romano scarpa ma
anche di questo trovato quasi Zero
online quasi tutte queste informazioni
le ho ritrovate da una singola
intervista a Loretta Magnani che sono
riuscito a trovare e a contattare su
Facebook e sto aspettando la risposta
sono
stanco
spettinato è tardi e sono in un hotel a
Roma il giorno prima della pubblicazione
che faccio un secondo aggiornamento
Perché odio che questo video non finisca
ho fatto tutto quello che ho potuto ma
non basta e non è giusto nei confronti
di un'opera come gatto Evaristo Quindi
vi chiedo un favore se avete delle
notizie aggiuntive o addirittura dei
Super 8 di Eva visto da volermi inviare
o da volermi passare un link digitali
quello che volete Mandatemi tutte le
informazioni possibili Scrivetemi dove
volete e facciamo una parte 2 perché io
voglio salvaguardarlo internet fai il
tuo cazzo di lavoro
[Musica]
buon compleanno Nord VPN per festeggiare
avrete uno sconto esclusivo tramite il
link ormai lo saprete tutti Siete in
viaggio volete connettervi alle reti
pubbliche in tutta sicurezza volete
vedere gatto Evaristo dall'estero con
nordvpn potete connettervi ad un IP
italiano per poterlo vedere come sempre
il codice sconto in descrizione